Great Nations are known for their great
buildings Egypt has the pyramids America
has the skyscraper but the people of
Tarragona Spain have surpassed them all
with their castles castles made from
human beings they call it Castel
this adds a whole new level to a family
fun day out this involves the whole
family the big dads on the bottom the
medium-sized women and men in the middle
and the tiny children at the top I mean
no one can escape the aim of castel is
to build and disassemble the highest
tower with your team
these Catalonian castles can reach eight
men high but no one man could carry
seven men on their shoulders so how are
they building them like all good
buildings I've put a lot of effort into
the foundation so they just got loads
and loads of people and crammed them in
and squash them as tight as possible and
the idea is if people can't move then
any force or load applied to them we'll
just get transferred to the next person
as they're pushed into them and that
will get transferred back and back and
back and so the more people you've got
at the bottom of the tower the more you
can share the total load amongst them
these castles are built with Spanish
smarts but when your bricks are human
they sure don't last forever and what
goes up must come down
I think the real question is would you
want to be the person falling from the
very top or would you want to be the
person at the very bottom with everyone
falling on top of you they must get
slightly repetitive working as a medic
Oh broken arm again how on earth did you
break your arm
climbing up seven levels of other people